bien sûr il est facile de dire que la
jeunesse d'un pays c'est son avenir
c'est son capital mais j'ai parfaitement
conscience que les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
sont confrontés aux défis d'un monde en
crise une crise dont la jeunesse n'est
pas responsable qu'elle subit il nous
faut à nous adultes responsables
leur tendre la main et trouver ce qui
est très difficile les moyens d'une
politique de la jeunesse qui ne soit pas
de l'assistanat mais qui permet à chaque
jeune de se construire un avenir de
façon autonome et si vous me permettez
libre et pendant trop longtemps
notre pays n'a pas offert à sa jeunesse
les perspectives auxquelles elle aspire
j'en veux pour preuve que depuis
plusieurs décennies
la france est l'un des pays d'europe
dont le plus grand nombre de jeunes sont
au chômage
quelles perspectives pour nos à voir si
nos jeunes sont au chômage
je veux tourner cette page et essayer de
bâtir avec vous une politique
structurelle de la jeunesse qui
affirment des choix dont certains sont
difficiles ce cas je vais m'expliquer
mais qui doit donner une chance à chaque
jeune quelle que soit son origine
quelles que soient ses talents quelles
que soient ses inspirations le 12
janvier dernier j'ai demandé à martin
hirsch qui est ici de travail et de
réfléchir
qu'est ce que peut-être qu'est ce que
pourrait être une politique de la
jeunesse et j'ai demandé à martin hirsch
deux d'inscrire cette politique autour
d'un projet l'autonomie c'est pas
évident
je pense c'est la première idée que je
me défende devant vous qu'une politique
de la jeunesse digne de ce nom
c'est une politique qui permettra
l'autonomie pour chaque jeune être
autonome ça veut pas dire refuser sa
famille ça va tu dois dire refuser son
milieu ça veut pas dire refuser ses amis
avoir les moyens de choisir sa propre
vie être autonome pendant quatre mois
martin lire ce que je remercie beaucoup
et les membres de sa commission ont
donné le meilleur d'eux-mêmes pour
formuler des propositions novatrices et
ambitieuse dans la commission il y avait
des gens de tous les bords politiques de
toutes les responsabilités je les en
remercie tous chacun a essayé de faire
un pas vers l'eau pour moi qu'est ce que
ça pouvait donner une politique de la
jeunesse
j'ai bien conscience qu'il n'est pas
facile pour les jeunes d'être jeune dans
la france d'aujourd'hui
j'ai bien conscience que les dans les
temps sont durs pour votre génération
qui pourrait nier qu'il soit plus
compliqué qu'avant pour un jeune de
devenir un adulte libre et pleinement
intégré d'un société ce n'est pas un
mystère
l'insertion professionnelle des jeunes
c'est un parcours du combattant
c'est difficile et nous n'avons pas
résolu cette question le monde
professionnel devrait ouvrir ses bras
aux jeunes c'est les jeunes qui avec
leur propre bras doivent s'ouvrir les
portes on a inversé le système le monde
professionnel devrait s'ouvrir
spontanément pour accueillir cette
richesse qu la jeunesse et on s'aperçoit
que ceux des jeunes qui intègrent le
monde professionnel sont ceux qui sont
battus je suis pas contre j'en connais
d'autres qui sont battus pour réussir
mais c'est pas tout à fait normal qu'on
doive se battre à ce point pour faire
valoir ses talents
on devrait se battre pour mériter la
chance qu'on vous donne pas se battre
poivre une chance le taux de chômage des
jeunes est durablement plus élevé que
celui des autres français les jeunes
sont davantage touchées par la pauvreté
que le reste de la population les
difficultés du logement sont multiples
et l'enchaînement des petits boulots
sont le lot quotidien de trop de jeunes
le décrochage des études l'importance
des sorties sans diplôme du système
éducatif constituent des symptômes
inquiétants du fossé qui se creuse entre
la société et les jeunes alors tout ceci
crée une inquiétude parmi la jeunesse
une crainte au fond d'un déclassement
moi je pense que ce qu'il ya de plus
frappant c'est que les jeunes de ma
génération on avait l'ambition d'avoir
un statut de la société plus importants
que ceux de nos parents et je pense qu à
l inverse
beaucoup de jeunes d'aujourd'hui ont
peur d'avoir un statut moins important
que la part je parle statut nos pensions
administratif du terme d'une place dans
la société d'un statut social comme l'on
dit même si c'est un peu caricatural
pendant des années nous sommes restés
trop figée et nous n'avons pas me
semble-t-il pris les tournants
nécessaires pour construire cette
société tout donne une chance à chaque
jeune
le marché du travail a séparé les
travailleurs insérer des précaires des
chômeurs et des jeunes une école à deux
vitesses une protection sociale
déséquilibré en défaveur des actifs et
des jamais et la jeunesse était la
première victime de notre incapacité
collective à nous réformer à abattre des
cloisons et plus on affirme l égalité
des chances
- on la vivait pour parler d'égalité des
chances on en a tous parlé mais qu'est
ce qu'il en est de la réalité et c'est
ce monde là que je souhaite changer avec
il faut refuser la dévalorisation du
travail et de l'effort
je pense que c'est une grave erreur de
refuser l'émulation scolaire
je pense que ça a été une très grave
erreur de placer l'élève à l'égal du
maître je pense que c'est une erreur de
chercher des excuses à ceux qui ne
respectent pas les règles élémentaires
la vie en société
je pense enfin que ce fut une erreur
d'ériger l'individu contre la famille au
lieu de promouvoir leur nécessaire
complémentarité
je le dis aux jeunes ceux qui ont fait
cela n'ont pas préparé votre avenir
parce que le monde est en train de
changer
et parce que le monde change vous avez
besoin de repères vous avez besoin de
valeurs oserais-je dire vous avez besoin
de morale vous avez des droits mais vous
avez aussi des devoirs
et ne pas parler de vos devoirs ses
mensonges et ses ne pas vous préparer à
l'avenir
alors à partir de ce moment comment on
va favoriser votre autonomie
l'autonomie dans mon esprit c'est la
faculté pour chacun d'entre vous de
faire ses propres choix et de les
assumer
parce que la contrepartie de la
possibilité de choisir c'est la
responsabilité du choix que vous aurez
fait ces libertés et responsabilités qui
sont dans mon esprit
opposé à dépendance et assistanat ce
désir d'autonomie
c'est le ciment de la jeunesse mais il
ne la rend pas uniforme
et c'est là où il ya la difficulté de la
politique que je vais exposer parce que
ça serait tellement simple martin qu'on
puisse dire les jeunes veulent être
autonomes et on amène le kit d'autonomie
mais n'existe pas parce que la jeunesse
est multiple enfin qui pourrait penser
que l'accès à l'autonomie dispose de la
même manière pour un jeune de seize ou
pour un un quasi adultes de 25 pour un
jeune en difficulté ou pour un jeune
d'une famille à statut social privilégié
et d'ailleurs est ce qu'on peut placer
sur le même plan un jeune travailleur un
diplômé et un décrocheur
la priorité n'est t'elle pas de répondre
d'abord aux besoins des jeunes qu'en
plus de difficultés il faut aider tous
les jeunes être autonome mais on ne peut
pas vous traiter tous de la même façon
je pense que l'égalité n'est pas
l'égalitarisme et qu'à force de dire que
tous les jeunes ont les mêmes droits
on nivelle
kir vers le bas parce que naturellement
la pas les moyens de donner à tous donc
il va falloir faire des choix aussi pour
aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est sur ces bases que nous voulons
construire votre autonomie
aucun jeune en difficulté ne sera laissé
seul ascenseur
aucun jeune ne sera laissé sans emploi
sans formation sans au cap un
accompagnement
comment allons-nous fait le premier
pilier il y en a quatre
c'est l'éducation le mois prochain avec
luc chatel j'exposerai les contours de
la réforme du lycée sur lequel nous
avons beaucoup travaillé
il n'est pas lieu d'en parler mais j'y
reviendrais parce que le lycée est un
carrefour majeur
si on réussit au lycée on a une chance
de s'en sortir si on échoue au lycée ce
sont des années de galère pour attraper
le train je dirai juste un mot sur ce
sujet qui est celui de l'orientation
il n'y a pas d'accès à l'autonomie sans
une école qui permettent un jeune de
choisir ce qu'il veut faire dans la vie
or le problème de l'orientation
aujourd'hui dans notre pays c'est
qu'elles n'existent pas ou si mal je
veux dire que l'idée qu'on peut choisir
sa vie à la suite d'un seul rendez-vous
ou d'une visite à la seule journée des
métiers
cette idée est absurde
de la même façon qu est extrêmement
condamnable idée qui consiste à demander
un jeune en seconde de faire un choix
qui serait définitif je plaide
pour que l'orientation soit progressive
sur tout le temps de la durée du lycée
seconde première terminale et que chaque
famille et chaque jeune ait le droit
jeudi le droit de revenir sur son choix
parce que c'est une injustice profonde
que celle qui consiste à pâtir de la
première à faire un choix de filière on
peut se tromper
ma volonté c'est qu'on puisse revenir
sur ce choix là et vous voyez bien là
tous vous n'êtes pas au lycée mais pour
ceux qui sont au lycée
l'idée c'est de dédramatiser
l'orientation qu'est vécu aujourd'hui
comme une au fond allez je veux dire à
montfort ont fait de la sélection sans
le dire on fait de la sélection par
l'échec et cette sélection là et les
scandaleuse parce qu'elle est
profondément injuste
je voudrais combien de jeunes se
retrouvent
sortie de la filière scientifique
non pas parce qu'ils ont choisi les
autres filières
mais parce qu'on les a désignés comme
des lycéens qui ne réussiront pas ce
n'est pas admissible
il y aura d'ailleurs dans le projet que
nous avons avec luc chatel d'autres
éléments
je tiens absolument à ce qu'on
rééquilibre les filières parce que tant
mieux pour ceux qui sont en filière
scientifique ça marche bien
n'y a aucune raison de pénaliser l'autre
moitié des lycéens qui sont en filière
littéraire ou qui sont en filière
économique
donc pour vous donner de l'autonomie on
va prendre des mesures qui permettront à
chacun de réfléchir à son avenir d'avoir
un véritable droit à la réorientation en
cours d'année pour qu'aucun jeune ne
reste durablement en situation d'échec
on fera un livret de compétences pour
ceux qui n'ont pas l'idée à 16 ans ou à
17 ans de ce qu'ils veulent faire toute
leur vie ce qu'est la majorité ce livret
de compétences permettra de mettre en
valeur leurs atouts et de les aider
petit à petit a décanté le choix qui est
qui sera le leur sans une orientation
performante
il n'y a pas de libre choix il n'y a pas
d'égalité des chances
nous allons réformer de fond en comble
le système d'orientation au lycée aucun
parmi vous ne sera laissé seul face aux
choix
vous serez et tuteur vous aurez des
conseillers vous aurez des rendez vous
tout au long de votre scolarité
vous aurez un livret de compétences vous
aurez le droit de choisir et de revenir
sur votre choix
absolument capital pour nous deuxième
pilier
l'insertion professionnelle je veux
donner la priorité absolue à une
catégorie de jeunes dont on ne sait
absolument pas occupé jusqu'à présent
qui sont les jeunes en rupture avec le
système éducatif
j'ai employé des mots forts mais je veux
être bien compris de la société
française nous allons mener une guerre
sans merci
une guerre sans merci contre le
décrochage scolaire
je n'accepterai pas que des jeunes
quittent l'école à 16 ans sans aucune
perspective
l'école est obligatoire jusqu'à 16 ans
il est des jeunes cent mille par an qui
disparaissent totalement dans notre
système
entre 16 ans et 18 ans pourquoi l'école
est obligatoire jusqu'à 16 ans il quitte
l'école à 16 ans personne n'a rien à
dire
et comme la plupart des dispositifs
commence à 18 ans il y à un véritable
trou noir scandaleux socialement coûteux
financièrement dramatique pour la
cohésion de la société ou cent mille
jeunes disparaissent de tous les
systèmes et de tous les processus et
naturellement ce sont les jeunes qui ont
le plus de difficultés sociales
naturellement ce sont les jeunes qui
souvent sont dans des familles que la
vie a explosé et qu'ils ne peuvent pas
ces familles se substituer à l'état
eh bien nous ne laisserons je les
appelle les décrocheurs
aucun d'entre eux ne sera livré à lui
même
dès la rentrée prochaine nous mettrons
en place dispositif où tous les jeunes
de 16 ans qui seront qui quitteront
l'école seront suivis répertoriés
on leur proposera une formation - emploi
aucun de ces jeunes ne restera abandonné
à lui même alors
c'est un enjeu dont j'ai parfaitement
confiance ce que je disais tout à
l'heure mais je pense profonde et cent
mille jeunes parents qui disparaissent
dont plus de personnes s'occupent à ceux
qui me disent attention tout ça coûte de
l'argent
ça coûte bien plus cher de sacrifier
cent mille jeunes d'une génération
chaque année en les laissant tomber
complètement à et tout le monde dorme
sur ses deux oreilles puisque c'est plus
problème de personne puisqu'ils sont
dans ce véritable triangle des bermudes
administratif où personne ne s'en occupe
alors nous allons faire évoluer
profondément nos systèmes aucun jeune ne
devra de sion ce ne sont pas des mots ce
sont des décisions
aucun jeune ne devra entre 16 et 18 ans
être laissé hors de tout système de
formation sauf s'il a déjà un emploi
ça ne sera pas un choix soit une
obligation
l'inactivité après l'absentéisme
scolaire l'inactivité ça ne prépare pas
la vie donc aucun ne sera sans formation
sauf s'il a déjà naturellement un emploi
c'est un droit pour les jeunes mais
c'est une obligation pour la nation nous
consacrerons ce droit et cette
obligation dans la loi et nous la
mettrons dans les faits alors la
prévention du décrochage va devenir
prioritaire pour l'éducation nationale
les formules d'enseignement adapté
seront développés à hauteur de l'enjeu
les médiateurs de réussite scolaire
poursuivre leur mobilisation sans faille
contre l'absentéisme dans chaque
établissement un référent sera désigné
pour soutenir les élèves fragiles
toute la communauté éducative sera
mobilisé tous les jeunes qui sortiront à
16 ans des systèmes scolaires on les
récupère à dans un système de formation
va travailler avec martin hirsch et avec
luc chatel avec toute l'équipe pour qu'
aucun ne passe au travers des mailles du
filet de la formation et au moment où
ces jeunes décrochent du système
éducatif
tout doit être fait pour les repérer
leur venir en aide
alors même que nombre d'entre eux
échappent aujourd'hui aux circuits
traditionnels un suivi systématique des
décrocheurs sera organisé entre les
institutions qui sont au contact des
jeunes à ce moment charnière
je pense rectorat au cfaa aux missions
locales qui sont regroupés au sein de
plateformes régionales d'orientation
dans chaque région on organisera une
plateformes régionales d'orientation en
fera l'un répertoriera la totalité des
décrocheurs et on leur proposera à
chacun une solution
nous allons expérimenter ce système dès
cette année et ce système sera
généralisé à la rentrée 2010 les
missions locales seront le pivot de
l'accompagnement des jeunes
nous leur attribueront des moyens
hauteur des résultats obtenus dans la
prise en charge des décrocheurs chaque
décrocheur chaque décrocheur aura un
parcours d'insertion qu'on va
contractualiser avec lui associant
droits et devoirs en financera le
parcours mais lui il assurera ses
obligations
tous les leviers d'insertion seront
mobilisés leurs profits contrat
d'apprentissage cher laurent wauquiez
place en école de la deuxième chance
contrat d'insertion
nous allons inventer des outils
complémentaires
martin hirsch va expérimenter un
mécanisme permettant référent des jeunes
de leur attribuer des aides
personnalisées pour qu'ils suivent
jusqu'au bout un parcours d'insertion
comme comprenne bien il ne s'agit pas de
mieux traiter un jeune qui décrochent
cas
jeune qui peut être en situation sociale
difficile qui suit ses études
mais le jeune qui décrochent qui se
battra qui assumera ses devoirs son
référent bénéficiera de moyens pour
l'aider est ce que c'est le permis de
conduire est ce que c'est le financement
d'une formation on en discutera martin
hisch expérimenté mais vous voyez bien
pour chacun d'entre eux on va
contractualiser devoirs et droits et les
aides que les référents pourront donner
à ces décrocheurs seront exclusivement
réservés aux jeunes décrocheurs qui
suivent assidûment une formation ceux
qui ne suivront pas une formation ne
font rien la société ne peut pas donner
des doigts et ne pas exiger des devoirs
on ne laissera personne tombée mais on
est vraiment dans la logique des droits
et des devoirs
nous devons jeter toutes nos forces dans
cette bataille même si j'ai bien
conscience que les décrocheurs ne sont
pas les seuls à faire face à ses
difficultés
mais vous voyez c'est très nouveau c'est
très ambitieux c'est très difficile mais
je ne peux pas me résoudre à laisser
cent mille jeunes français par an partir
à la dérive au prétexte qu'ils ne
correspondent pas aux critères de
sélection administrative que nous avons
dans notre pays depuis cinq décennies
c'est pas possible la politique c'est
pas simplement le virtuel salon est plus
réelle et nous allons engager la guerre
sans merci contre les décrocheurs
alors ce ne sont pas les seuls à
connaître des difficultés d'insertion
laurent wauquiez auxquels je rends
hommage et que je remercie a mis en
place un plan d'urgence pour l'emploi
des jeunes en contrat d'apprentissage
plus attractif multiplication des places
en école de deuxième chance
faciliter l'embauché des stagiaires sous
statut de cdi on n'a cessé depuis ce
matin de me parler de la question des
stages et de la difficulté de
l'insertion
professionnel mais on va aller encore
plus loin pourquoi les pré recrutement
ne serait-il pas autorisé pour que les
entreprises qui le souhaitent financent
les études d'un jeune en échange d'un
engagement de ce dernier a travaillé en
leur sein à la fin de sa formation
ça s'appelle de la fidélisation pourquoi
ne pas le permettre
ça donnerait des ressources aux iut au
centre d'apprentissage et ça permet à
des jeunes d'être tranquille en
formation se disant à la sortie de ma
formation j'ai un contrat et ça permet à
l'entreprise de planifier son
recrutement et bien conformément à la
loi sur le dialogue social
je demande dès aujourd'hui aux
partenaires sociaux de se saisir avec
laurent wauquiez de cette question le
contrat d'insertion dans la vie sociale
sera renforcée je demande que l'on testé
formules nouvelles par exemple en
expérimentant un mécanisme dans lequel
le jeune en contrepartie d'un soutien de
l'état sera tenu d'accepter toute
proposition d'emploi ou de formation
l'alternance sera au coeur de nos
priorités nous allons améliorer statut
des apprentis pour qu'ils bénéficient
davantage inspirés de ceux aujourd'hui
accordée aux étudiants car je le dis
sous le contrôle de verre et pécresse
c'est quand même extraordinaire
d'expliquer que l'apprentissage doit
être valorisée et de donner aux
apprentis - qu'est-ce qu'on donne aux
étudiants
c'est de l'injustice et je n'accepterais
pas cette injustice
là aussi c'est la différence entre la
réalité et les mots si on veut
revaloriser lapentti donnons à
l'apprenti les mêmes avantages cas
l'étudiant on n'oppose pas les uns aux
autres on dit l'apprenti comme
l'étudiant ou choisi un parcours
d'excellence la fonction publique
nous allons l'ouvrir à l'apprentissage
rendez vous compte qu alors que l'état
depuis des années plaide pour le
développement de l'apprentissage
il ya moins de 6000 apprentis dans la
fonction publique
là est un scandale parce que cela
consiste pour l'état à dire aux
entreprises faites ce que je dis et
surtout pas ce que je fais et quelle est
la crédibilité de l'état de pousser les
entreprises à proposer des places
d'apprentissage est lui même dans ses
propres services de ne pas en donner
l'apprenti ou l'apprentissage c'est pas
simplement les trains les travaux
manuels
il y à des tables de même dans la
fonction publique où nous devons prendre
des jeunes apprentis pour les aider à se
préparer à la situation qui sera la leur
dans la société
enfin dans les universités avec valérie
pécresse qui y amener tous chantiers de
réformes brillamment nous allons
développer l'alternance en fin de cursus
partout c'est possible là aussi cette
extraordinaire
pourquoi l'alternance ne serait pas
possible en fin de cursus à l'université
l'alternance n'est pas réservée
simplement à bac + 2 et sa frappe du
beaucoup de bien à nombre d'étudiants y
compris à des niveaux élevés de
commencer en alternance pourquoi vous
voyez je voudrais que on rapproche les
statuts et ça permettra de donner
davantage de concret et d'insertion
professionnelle aux étudiants et en même
temps aux familles des apprentis ou de
la formation professionnelle comme à ces
jeunes la reconnaissance de la nation
nous allons aller plus loin dans
l'encadrement des stages prévoir une
rémunération minimale pour les stages de
plus de deux mois était une étape
nécessaire mais pour éviter les abus
il faut définir clairement ce dont on
parle le stage est une étape dans un
parcours de formation il n'est pas un
sous statut permettant aux entreprises
d'éviter de recruter des salariés
je vais
claire sur le sujet je soutiens les
entreprises chef d'entreprise d'un
métier extrêmement difficile et c'est
utile à la nation
mais le stage c'est un parcours de
formation ce n'est pas un sous statut
je n'accepterai pas que le stage
devienne un sous-statut je prends un
stagiaire parce que c'est plus
tranquille que d'embaucher un salarié
cela je ne pourrais pas l'accepter dans
aucun cas et dans aucune situation alors
tout stage doit donc s'inscrire dans une
perspective claire pour le jeune dans le
cadre de ses études et d'un accès futur
à l'emploi c'est la raison pour laquelle
les stages hors cursus seront interdits
le stage c'est pour le cursus hors
cursus pas de style moraliser listage
mais je vous dire une chose c'est
montrer à la jeunesse qu'elle a le droit
d'être respectés et d'être considérés
moi je veux bien dire à la jeunesse
droits et devoirs mais il faut les
respecter et c'est pas parce qu'on est
jeune qu'on n'a pas être respecté et un
stage qui ne serait pas un cursus mais
un sous-statut c'est manquer de respect
à quelqu'un qui devrait un salarié
protégé par un droit social
j'y reviendrai alors j'en viens à une
question extrêmement importante à mes
yeux est une conviction depuis bien
longtemps
nous devons tout faire pour valoriser
les jeunes travailleurs et je veux dire
quelque chose qui est à mes yeux un
véritable scandale et qui fait que j'ai
toujours été opposé à des contrats
jeunes à statut social inférieur
je n'ai je n'accepte pas l'idée que
parce qu'on est jeune on a moins de
droits sociaux que quand on est adulte
et est par exemple il est profondément
anormal qu'un jeune
qui a commencé à travailler tôt n'ait
pas le droit au rsa
s'il a moins de 25 ans je conteste
l'idée je la conteste que 25 ans soit
une limite au-delà de laquelle on a un
droit et en deçà de laquelle on perd ce
droit mais qui peut comprendre que dans
la même entreprise
le travailleur de 25 ans et six mois a
le droit au rsa c'est à dire d'avoir
leurs revenus de son travail plus les
allocations et dans la même entreprise
de même travailleur de 24 ans et 6 mois
n'a pas le droit ou n'auraient pas le
droit du salaire plus ces allocations au
prétexte que depuis trente ans la règle
25 ans s'applique elle n'a aucun sens
elle est choquante
je le dis donc de la façon de plus clair
je veux y mettre un terme parce que je
considère comme anormal qu'à durée de
travail égal on traite différemment deux
salariés au motif exclusif que l'un est
plus jeune que l'autre qui peut accepter
ça pourquoi le cip et fut une erreur
et pourquoi le cpe fut une erreur parce
qu'il est inacceptable dans la société
française qu'on n'ait pas les mêmes
droits sociaux selon qu'on est l âge ou
tel autre alors les b les français ne
peuvent pas bénéficier de droits sociaux
différents sur la seule base de leur âge
ce n'est pas ma conception de la justice
sociale
ce n'est pas de cette manière qu'on
encouragera ceux qui prennent tôt leurs
responsabilités d'adulte voici pourquoi
nous avons décidé d'ouvrir le bénéfice
du rsa aux travailleurs de moins de 25
ans
c'est un changement considérable gens
mesurent les risques mais je ne veux pas
qu'il y ait d'ambiguïté entre nous mon
intention n'est pas d'instaurer un rmi
jeune que j'ai
toujours refusé tout au long de ma vie
politique
un rmi jeune qui consisterait à faire de
nos jeunes des assistés
le bénéfice du rsa sera réservé aux
jeunes qui sont déjà dans le monde
professionnel qui ont travaillé déjà
deux ans sur une période de trois ans
ces jeunes méritent ces jeunes
travailleurs méritent que la nation
valorisent leurs efforts vous le voyez
bien maintenant à moins de 25 ans si on
a travaillé deux ans sur une période de
trois ans on aura le droit au rsa
si on n'a pas travaillé deux ans on
n'ira pas le droit pourquoi parce que je
ne veux pas durer michel parce que je ne
veux pas de l'assistanat
parce que je souhaite valoriser les
travailleurs jeunes ou moins jeunes
c'est un nouveau droit social pour les
jeunes travailleurs dans notre pays
ça a été premier par tout le monde
depuis des années eh bien aujourd'hui
c'est chose faite je le dis à mes
propres amis politiques
je ne crains pas le débat tu es la
majorité doit être une majorité ouverte
sur la justice sur la justice n'est pas
sur l'idéologie
j'ai été élu sur la revalorisation du
travail et sur la justice la
revalorisation du travail c'est un jeune
travailleur puisse avoir le rsa
la justice c'est qu'un jeune de moins de
25 ans puisse être traité comme un un un
salarié de 26 ans ça c'est la justice
mais je ne tourne pas le dos à mes
valeurs
l'assistanat non le rmi jeunes non il
faudra travailler mais c'est un progrès
me semble-t-il social immense c'est un
changement dans les habitudes de notre
pays
j'ai parfaitement conscience de ce que
ça remet en cause comme d'habitude mais
j'en attends que les jeunes considèrent
qu'ils sont respectés qu'ils ont les
mêmes droits que les autres et donc
qu'on pourra leur demander les mêmes
devoirs connaissance
il ya aussi la capacité à s'assumer
financièrement permettent aux jeunes de
s'assumer financièrement c'est agir sur
tous les leviers qui détermine le niveau
de vie des jeunes est d'abord leur
qualification la hausse du niveau de
formation je vraiment vous savez moi
j'essaie de dire ce que je pense au fond
de moi sans complaisance j'ai un travail
à faire
j'ai un devoir assumer et c'est ce que
je fais
s'il n'y a pas de hausse de votre niveau
de formation vous aurez un déclassement
social
tout passe pour vous par la hausse de
votre niveau de formation quel que soit
par ailleurs ces formations quelle que
soit par ailleurs le domaine mais c'est
déterminant l'enseignement supérieur et
le moteur de l'ascension sociale de
garder des chances
je veux parler du rythme universitaire
et valérie pécresse qu confiance bien
sûr va poursuivre résolument
l'allongement de la durée effective de
l'année universitaire écoutez c'est pas
possible qu'on ne voit pas qu'il y a là
un problème majeur
je propose dans toutes les filières qui
le nécessitent que les universités porte
à dix mois la durée annuelle des
formations comme c'est déjà le cas dans
certains cursus avec valérie nous
entièrement confiance aux présidents
d'université et à leurs équipes pour
trouver la meilleure manière de mettre
en eux ces orientations
elle suppose naturellement d'adapter le
service offert aux jeunes mais n'y a
aucune raison que l'année universitaire
soit si courte
on peut pas dire il faut élever le
niveau des formations et raccourcir la
durée de l'année universitaire donc nous
allons poursuivre avec valérie
l'allongement de la durée de l'année
universitaire je vous annonce que
désormais chaque année au mois de
septembre au mois de septembre les
étudiants auront pleinement accès aux
bibliothèques et aux salles
informatiques
parce que naturellement si je dis ça et
que les salles informatiques et les
bibliothèques sont fermés dans pas
fonctionné une fois la durée des
formations effectivement étendu un 10e
mois de bourse sera accordée pour
permettre aux jeunes de condition
modeste d'avoir les mêmes chances que
les autres de russie aujourd'hui valérie
les bourses et 9 mois on va
progressivement allongé la durée de
l'année universitaire et naturellement
on va essayer d'être juste juste à ce
moment là on peut pas dire on allonge la
durée universitaire mais on laisse la
durée des bourses dont comportera à ce
moment là mais c'est la même logique
droit et devoir allonger la durée de la
formation annuelle et nous allongeons le
versement le nombre de mois de versement
des bourses
nous le devons aux français qui paient
les impôts et ils font que les études
sont gratuites mais je le dis aussi les
étudiants devront s'engager à respecter
l'obligation d'assiduité
il n'y a pas de droits sont contents
tous partis de devoir oui nous sommes
prêts à allonger la durée des bourses
oui nous sommes prêts à ouvrir les
bibliothèques et les salles
informatiques des 70
je le dis aussi nous sommes prêts à
renforcer les contrôles pour que la
société française soit assuré que ceux
qui ont des études gratuites ou des
bourses respecte les règles d'assiduité
minimum pas de droits sans devoirs
alors permettent aux jeunes de s'assumer
financièrement il n'y a pas de solution
unique ça serait tellement simple mais
le réalisme nous invite à concentrer les
moyens sur les personnes les plus en
difficulté pour identifier les formules
les plus utiles
martens disposera sur les deux
prochaines années d'une enveloppe de 50
millions d'euros qui lui permettra de
procéder à des expérimentations qui nous
permettront de les généraliser pour
celle ensuite qui fonctionneront je
demande simplement un martin qu'il
respecte plusieurs impératifs un
objectif d'amélioration du taux d'emploi
ou de formation des jeunes concernés et
l'exigence de réelle contrepartie de
leur part et une durée suffisamment
longue pour que leurs effets puisse être
mesurée l'idée est simple nous ne
voulons pas pour notre jeunesse
d'assistanat tourner le dos à
l'assistanat
il n'y a aucune espérance dans
l'assistanat mais ce qu'ils saisiront
leur chance on va les aider et les aider
puis 5 par ailleurs pour les jeunes qui
ont une aspiration particulière à
l'autonomie martin hirsch m'a proposé je
les accepte et d'expérimenter un
mécanisme de dotation destinée à
permettre aux jeunes de bénéficier lui
même d'une partie des aides publiques
qui sont aujourd'hui attribué à ses
parents alors je sais que cette idée ne
fait pas consensus
c'est pas une raison pour qu'on la met
de côté et qu'on n'en parle pas moi je
pense qu il faut faire des
expérimentations et tester cela avec les
garde-fous nécessaires pour que les
termes du débat soit clarifiée mais dans
ce cadre le jeune aura la possibilité de
financer des dépenses utiles comme son
permis de conduire ou l'accès à un
logement
en tout cas je souhaite je le dis aux
parlementaires qu'on fasse cette
expérimentation pour les jeunes qui le
veulent pour des dépenses utiles
est ce qu'il ne faut pas sur les
allocations de la famille voir une
partie de ses allocations versées je
parle des jeunes majeurs aux jeunes je
ne ferai pas la généralisation
maintenant parce que c'est trop complexe
je veux entendre les termes du débat
mais pourquoi refuser une
expérimentation
ça aussi c'est de l'autonomie alors est
ce qu on veut que nos jeunes soient
autonomes ou est ce qu'on veut qu'il
soit insisté
on peut pas dire ils doivent être
autonomes et pas assister et en même
temps dire attention sur les allocations
versées à la famille je n'accepte pas
qu'on en parle par onze ans
expérimentons martin va voir les
associations familiales
les parlementaires se saisiront de ce
débat nous en débattrons et nous verrons
les conclusions à en tirer
d'autres actions seront engagées pour
mieux protéger la santé du jeune l'aide
à l'acquisition d'une complémentaire je
vous la noce sera doublée à partir de
l'année prochaine
là aussi on ne peut pas plaisanter avec
la santé de nos jeunes c'est pas
possible
tout le monde me parle de politique de
prévention la première politique de
prévention c'est permettent aux jeunes
d'avoir une complémentaire nous allons
doubler l'aide pour la complémentaire
problèmes d'accès au logement
nous allons inciter les bailleurs privés
alloués aux jeunes la location jeunes ne
doit plus être considérée comme un
risque pour les propriétaires elle doit
au contraire devenir vraiment attractive
enfin dernier pilier de l'autonomie
l'engagement toute ma vie moi j'ai été
engagé et peu importe que ce soit dans
la politique je me sens une proximité
avec tous ceux qui s'engagent mouvement
syndical mouvement politique mouvement
associatif
peu importe on doit faire quelque chose
de sa vie et vous n'en ferez rien si
vous ne vous engagez pas regarder la vie
de façon distante comme extérieur
n'amène rien l'engagement et la clé
l'engagement c'est la clé d'une
génération solidaire qui s'impliquent et
bien le service civique
à mes yeux entre pleinement dans ce
projet d'une société qui s'engage
moi je souhaite une société qui s'engage
même si on peut être en désaccord mais
je trouve toujours plus de noblesse à
celui qui veut être acteur cas celui qui
veut être spectateur un service civique
volontaire parce que l'engagement est un
don de soi un service civique ambitieux
nous allons commencer dès 2010 à offrir
à dix mille jeunes la possibilité d'un
service civique qui concernera à terme
10% d'une classe d'âge à peu près 70
mille jeunes vous voyez donc qu'on
commence par 10000 dès 2010
quand même significatif on ira jusqu'à
70 milles et offrait un point ce moment
là pour voir si on va développer encore
le système
ce service civique sera consacré à des
activités utiles pour la société
ce nouveau creuset de la citoyenneté
sera donc créée avant la fin de l'année
sur la base des propositions novatrices
formulée par luc ferry auquel je tiens à
rendre un hommage appuyé pour la qualité
de son travail souple dans ses modalités
ce service civique sera facilement
accessible aux jeunes est simple pour
les organismes qui vont les accueillir
il sera un instrument de mixité sociale
qui permettra de faire se côtoyer des
jeunes qui sans lui ne vais jamais une
chance de se rencontrer et franchement
notre pays a bien besoin de mixité
sociale le service militaire n'avait pas
que des qualités
je les fais mais ça fait aussi du bien à
beaucoup de jeunes de se mélanger de se
rencontrer et de passer un moment
ensemble
il n'est absolument pas question bien
sûr
le rétablit du service militaire mais
l'objectif dans tous les discours aux
pentes de mixité sociale et on en fait
de moins en moins et bien ce service
civique sera l'occasion de faire il sera
pleinement reconnue et valorisée
parce que les jeunes qui font le service
public en seront récompensées dans leurs
études ou dans l'accès à l'emploi
je crois beaucoup à cela un site un
engagement que j'avais pris dans ma
campagne
il ya un don de soi des jeunes la
société a besoin de ce don alors ça
pourrait être dans une ong
ça pourrait être à l'extérieur s'apprête
à l'international mais ça pourrait
opérer des personnes âgées
ça pourrait être dans un lycée ça
pourrait dans une association
mais bon il ya des jeunes qui ont envie
de donner
de même qu'ils ont pas forcément choisi
après le bac
une orientation professionnelle et qui
ont lieu pensé à eux mêmes peuvent se
réaliser en allant vers les autres et
bien c'est ça le service civil sera donc
volontaire mais il existe en et j'en
attends beaucoup et on va se débrouiller
pour le valoriser à la fois pour vos
études pour votre insertion
professionnelle on est en train de
travailler dessus
martin fera des propositions mais mais
dans mon esprit c'est quelque chose de
très important qui est aussi une preuve
de confiance jeunesse on peut être
passionné par l'afrique on peut être
passionné par le développement peut être
passionné par la santé on peut avoir une
expérience dans un hôpital on peut se
mettre au service pourquoi refuser cette
générosité
est-ce que c'est pas et vous voyez la
grande logique entre aucun décrocheurs
accepté tous une formation aucun don de
soi refusé le service
si oui l'autonomie pour chacun des
études université avec une année un peu
plus longue
il ya une logique qui est celle de fonds
nous vous faisons confiance
c'est ça que je suis venu vous dire et
tout ce que nous mettons sur la table
c'est pour dire aux jeunes de notre pays
nous vous faisons confiance
mais vous faire confiance c'est vous
donner des droits et vous mettre devant
vos responsabilités et c'est ça le rsa
moins de 25 ans c'est cela les moyens
pour lui les tuteurs ou les référents
que nous allons donner on va récompenser
aider celui qui prend la main qu'on lui
tend alors bientôt j'ai déjà été trop
long je m'en excuse auprès de vous bien
d'autres horizons seront ouverts nous
allons poser la question de l'un la
mobilité européenne
là encore je le dis à valérie il n'y a
aucune raison que le programme erasmus
soit réservé aux seuls étudiants les
plus brillants tant mieux mais
formidable sa marge
moi je veux un erasmus des apprentis il
n'y a aucune raison que des jeunes
apprentis ne puisse pas aller suivre 20
ou alors ou alors si tel devait être le
cas
c'est qu'on considère qu'un jeune
apprenti vaut moins qu'un jeune étudiant
alors qu'on le dise mais si on ne le
pense pas alors nous allons mettre sur
pied un erasmus des apprentis ou des
formations techniques et
professionnelles pour que un jeune en
formation professionnelle puisse autant
profiter de l'expérience des d autre qu
un jeune étudiant
j'ajoute que la représentation
institutionnelle des jeunes sera modifié
parce que je ferai rentrer un certain
nombre de représentants des mouvements
de jeunes dans le conte conseil
économique social et environnemental que
la réforme de la constitution oblige à
modifier
écoutez quand présente une institution
comme les forces vives de la nation il
n'y avait pas le jeune
alors des gens les forces tout court
j'avais moi même ça me faire des ennuis
ce que je vais dire mais enfin lorsque
j'ai été installé comme président la
république c'est qu'on est élu président
de la république
et puis qu'on attend 15 jours et on vous
installe j'étais donc reçu dans la
grande salle des fêtes de l'élysée et le
président du conseil constitutionnel
donne les résultats et je deviens à ce
moment-là président de la république
devant les forces vives de la nation
c'est très révélateur
c'est très révélateur c'est très
révélateur et forces vives de la nation
il n'y avait pas de jeunes j'étais par
les deux fois au conseil économique est
une institution de qualité de dialogue
social où les rapports sont passionnants
où les gens sont motivés mais j'ai vu si
peu de femmes si peu de jeunes ce n'est
pas la conception que je me fais les
choses
voilà mesdames et messieurs j'espère que
vous avez compris même maire d'avignon
pour moi c'était très important de venir
ici pour parler de cette politique de la
jeunesse sur laquelle tant de
gouvernements tant de majorité se sont
cassé les dents
non pas par mauvaise volonté mais parce
que la jeunesse c'est un monde si
multiples un couple de 22 ans qui a un
enfant n'a pas les mêmes besoins les
mêmes aspirations les mêmes problèmes
qu'un jeune de 25 ans qui est en
troisième cycle de doctorat à
l'université et qui vit encore chez ses
parents
c'est un monde multiple et pourtant
cette jeunesse si multiples elle est
l'avenir de la nation
et c'est pas parce que ces multiples
parce que c'est difficile parce que
c'est complexe parce que les mots
peuvent être mal interprétés par fois
qu'il ne faut pas essayer de poser les
bases d'une authentique politique de la
jeunesse
si ce à quoi je me suis essayée devant
vous je n'ai pas voulu faire un discours
grandiloquents avec citation à la pluie
sur la jeunesse son avenir ses problèmes
ses bonheurs son spleen ses désirs
parce que ça c'est le plus facile à
faire j'ai voulu essayer d'apporter des
réponses concrètes sur des noeuds de
rupture auxquelles il convient de
s'attaquer fortement voilà nous aurons
parlement un débat et je voudrais dire
aussi combien sur connaissant un valérie
pécresse laurent wauquiez à martin hertz
de 2,7 occuper de cela ils sont
différents
nous sommes différents et pourtant c'est
retrouver sur cette politique là parce
que je crois que cette politique là et
n'est ni de gauche ni de droite
elle est d'intérêt général pour tous et
c'est ça qui compte
je sais parfaitement
que nous serons jugés je serai jugé au
résultat j'y suis prêt mais pendant les
cinq années de mon mandat
mon devoir c'est de prendre des
décisions d'assumer des choix et dans un
monde qui bouge à la vitesse oui bauges
de faire bouger notre pays qui ne peut
pas rester immobile qui ne peut pas
rester conservateurs qui ne peut pas
avoir peur de sa jeunesse
j'ai confiance j'ai confiance en vous
merci